>>female presenter: Good afternoon, everyone.
Authors at Google New York is very pleased
to welcome Joshua David and Robert Hammond,
who are neighbors of ours here in New York.
And they are responsible for the High Line.
I mean, how much more do I have to say?
[applause]
>>Joshua David: Thank you all for joining
us today.
I'm Josh.
That's Robert.
And we wrote a book that came out in October.
Oh, my shirt's undone.
And it's called "High Line: The--."
I forget the subtitle now.
It has a longer subtitle.
But it's about the High Line and it's on sale
in the back.
And Google has very generously arranged to
have it be at a discount to all of you.
So, it's ten dollars.
It's a great buy.
And we've been wanting to come and talk to
you a little bit about it for a few months
now and the date kept moving around a little.
So, we're thrilled to be here.
It's really an incredible journey that we've
been on and a lot of folks who work at Google
have been on with us as well over the past
12 years or so from when we started Friends
of the High Line to where we are now, where
we have nearly four million visitors a year
coming to the High Line.
And so, it's hard to imagine when you go up
there now to imagine that once this was not
open to the public, was threatened with demolition,
was going to be torn down.
It was a very different scenario just 12 years
ago.
And our book tells a little bit of that story.
So you know this well, but this is the map
of where the High Line runs along the West
Side of Manhattan.
These were the conditions that led to the
construction of the High Line.
Trains started running down the West Side
in the 1860s.
And immediately, people were getting killed
by the intersection of train traffic and other
kinds of vehicles--horse-drawn carts, cars,
and pedestrians.
And the avenues became known as Death Avenue
because of these collisions.
And because of that, the City of New York
required that a man on horseback had to ride
in front of each train.
They were called the West Side Cowboys.
And this is one of them.
This is the High Line under construction.
It started construction in 1929 and went to
1934.
And you can see another elevated structure
to the left in this image, which was the old
Miller elevated highway.
There used to be an elevated highway along
the West Side that was built around the same
time.
More construction shots.
And this is the High Line when it was completed
in 1934 and trains started running on it.
And one of the interesting things about the
way that it was built and the way that it
was used was trains actually were supposed
to go through buildings.
They loaded and unloaded directly into warehouses
and factories.
And that was an efficiency system.
And it's one of the things that makes the
High Line such an interesting part of the
built environment today.
This is the way that I first saw the High
Line from the ground and Robert as well.
I live in Chelsea.
Robert lives in the Village.
We didn't know each other.
Became interested in this odd relic that ran
through our neighborhoods.
But never really saw it from up above, only
saw it from the bottom.
And thought, "Wow.
That's an interesting structure and maybe
something interesting could be done with it."
This is the landscape that grew up on top
of it after the trains stopped running.
This was a photograph that was taken by photographer
named Joel Sternfeld in around 2000.
But we didn't even see this when we started
Friends of the High Line.
We just saw it from the street and thought
it was something amazing.
We happened to meet at a community board meeting
in 1999.
We were both the only two people there who
thought that something should happen to the
High Line other than it being torn down.
Everybody was there was in favor of demolishing
it.
But we thought this runs for 22 blocks, through
three different neighborhoods.
Here's an amazing opportunity to create a
new way of seeing the city.
>>Robert Hammond: So, Josh was a travel writer
before this.
And my background was in little bit internet
start-ups.
And so, people think, "Oh."
Someone asks, "Can we see your business plan
for how you were thinking about starting the
High Line?"
And we really had no plan.
We had no money.
And we really had no relevant experience.
People assume we're architects or designers.
And in some ways, that's one of the keys to
the success of the High Line was not having
a plan.
[laughs] And not having any experience because
we really--.
And it's great 'cause now Josh and I get all
this credit for doing this.
But the most important thing we did was really
just raise the flag and allowed other people
to come along to help us that did have the
experience and that did have the money.
And that helped us coalesce around a plan.
We also had a lot of opposition.
And now, the High Line is generally pretty
popular, but at the time, everyone really
wanted to tear it down.
The developers in the neighborhood wanted
to tear it down.
People in the community, some of them it was
a reminder they lived in a bad neighborhood
in the past because the trains used to run
through it.
But this guy was our main opponent--Giuliani.
And but it turned out it actually started
working in our favor because if people weren't
interested in the history or the pretty pictures,
the wildflowers, we could say, "Well, Giuliani
hates it and wants to--."
[laughter]
And they'd be like, "Oh, well then it must
be a great idea."
[laughter]
"I would love to help you."
The other thing that we really concentrated
on early on was design.
So, one of the very first things we did was
get a logo.
And it's still on our business card.
And it's now the logo of the park.
And it was designed by a woman named Paula
Scher from Pentagram.
And the goal was one, to make us look like--.
This is what someone, one of our critics used
to say is this project's just two guys and
a logo.
Which we thought was a compliment.
But it made us feel like we were more than
just two guys working out of their apartments.
And so, it was also a commitment to design,
that we weren't just, if we were successful,
we weren't just gonna throw up a stair and
a planter and call it a day.
We were actually gonna--.
Good design was gonna follow all the through
if we ever wanted to build something up there.
So, going back to this Joel Sternfeld photo,
because this was also one of the keys to the
success was these photos.
So, this photographer, Joel Sternfeld, went
up there and he took pictures for us for one
year, between 2000 and 2001.
And we published it in a book called "Walking
the High Line."
And there's some of the photos in our book.
But you just see it in all different seasons.
And this is really what people feel in love
with, especially this picture was the key
to the success.
We realized we could just talk less and show
this photo more and often.
And this is what helped people just imagine
their own dreams of what could be done with
the High Line.
This is--.
I don't know how many of y’all remember
the restaurant Florent.
It used to be on Gansevoort.
This is Florent.
It was like a French bistro.
It was one of the first things in this neighborhood.
It was open 24 hours.
People would go after going to clubs.
And every Bastille Day, Florent would dress
up as Marie Antoinette.
And this year, he did the Marie Antoinette
as the High Line with the train going around
the bustle and the hat.
>>male #1: [inaudible ]
>>Robert Hammond: I know.
I know.
It's sad now.
But I think he's happier now that he doesn't
have the restaurant.
So, but the reason I put this slide up there
is also--.
Well, I'll go to the next slides.
It's more exciting.
We thought we'd--.
A semi-nude photo and if you're getting a
little sleepy at lunch, it could liven things
up.
Because one of the early keys to the success
was the gay community.
Josh and I are both gay.
And those were a lot of the people that lived
in the neighborhood.
Those were just our friends.
And so, they really coalesced around this
project.
And this is a talk we gave at the center a
while ago about the role, not just of the
gay community that helped us, but the role
that the gay community has played in preservation
projects all over the city and the world.
>>Joshua David: Still going?
>>Robert Hammond: Yup.
So, Mayer Bloomberg came in office.
He was more supportive than Giuliani, but
9/11 had happened.
We were in an economic crisis.
He didn't care about the pictures of Joel
Sternfeld's wildflowers and he didn't care
about the naked guy on the High Line really.
He cared more if it made economic sense.
So, we commissioned an economic feasibility
study by a guy named John Alschuler at a firm
called HR and A, to prove that it made economic
sense.
So, we looked--.
The best example of a park really creating
value is Central Park.
We said, "OK.
Central Park's too big, too popular.
Let's look at parks no one's ever heard of."
That means some of y’all might 'cause it's
around the neighborhood like the Christopher
Park, Duane Park.
And the buildings around those parks are more
valuable to anywhere from six to thirteen
percent.
We also met with real estate marketers.
And they said the real way you create more
value is you create a district, a place people
wanna work in, live in, visit, shop in.
And so, we started--.
We'd already started thinking about the High
Line as a connector of different things and
this is map that actually, the woman who did
our logo, drew of the neighborhood, Paula
Scher.
And it just listed all the different things
happening.
It was helping us show that this could connect
it all together.
'Cause the West Village wasn't as popular
at the time.
And so, the study showed--.
We got the study actually wrong.
This is the findings.
We thought it would cost a hundred million
to build.
So far, it's cost about 150 million.
And we said over a 20-year time period, the
incremental tax benefits to the city would
be about 250 million dollars.
The city has recently revised those numbers
and it's coming in more like 900 million dollars.
So, it turns out to have been a good investment.
The city was actually--.
We didn't really believe these numbers [laughs]
when we presented them.
We were fluffing them up.
>>Joshua David: Mmm.
>>Robert Hammond: But the city believed enough
of them to go forward and really got behind
the project.
And so, but even in 2003, with the city behind
us, we just really, we still had no money.
We had more of maybe a vague plan.
And we still, the property owners that owned
property underneath were suing the city to
tear it down.
So, and no one knew what the High Line was.
It's like, you asked people the thing and
you say, "Oh, the thing with pigeon shit when
you go under it."
And they go, "Oh, that thing.
I hate that thing."
But so, we did an ideas competition.
And it was really just to create awareness
of the project and have people think about
it in different ways.
And this was one of our favorites for many
reasons.
But it was a mile-long lap pool,--
[laughter]
which I still think would be an amazing idea.
Some of the other concepts were more artistic,
like turning it into this icon.
This was more of a political manifesto, where
you would imprison people in the I-beams of
the High Line.
And I don't know why they put a pool in there,
too, but--.
This, I think, was playing off of "High,"
maybe--High Line.
And then, this--.
This was actually looking at programming.
What would happen in and around the High Line?
And this is what's really come true so much.
It's not just what happens on the High Line,
but what happens in the neighborhood all around
it.
This was our favorite, was the mile-long roller
coaster.
[laughter]
And this possibly could have been better than
what we did 'cause you leave it all just as
it was and then this urban scene, seeing people's
apartments and zoom down.
And we had the exhibition at Grand Central
because the idea was to not make it just a
local project, but to make it that this is
important for the whole city.
And we also--.
Josh and I didn't have a specific vision on
what we thought should go up there.
And that was one of the advantages of not
being an architect.
We said, "The city, the community, should
decide what was up there."
So, we started doing a whole bunch of open
houses.
And this is a postcard asking people what
you want, where we asked them, "What do you
wanna see up there?"
Even before we really started designing, we've
now done about probably over, way over a dozen
of these.
We just had one about two weeks ago for the
new section.
And you'll see some of the designs for that.
And we're gonna have more.
We'll have another one this summer.
If you're interested, just sign up for an
email newsletter or Facebook.
We're getting Google+.
[laughter]
And we partnered--.
We've had to fight Giuliani, but then it was
really about partnering with government.
And Bloomberg was very supportive.
Christine Quinn, who's now the speaker of
the City Council, lives in the neighborhood,
Hilary Clinton, Chuck Schumer, Jerry Nadler
all really got behind the project and it became
really a public/private partnership.
I love this photo 'cause none of them are
looking at each other.
[laughter]
They can all stand together, but not have
to acknowledge each other.
So, when we got the political support, we
still needed to get the property owners on-board.
So, we actually looked, again, at Grand Central.
And everyone knows there are a lot of--.
You might have heard the story of Jackie O.,
how she saved Grand Central from being demolished.
But the other part of the story is one of
the ways they saved it was they allowed the
owners, the railroad, to transfer development
rights anywhere in the neighborhood.
It's also what saved the theaters and Times
Square in the 90s.
And so, we used the same mechanism.
And it had only been used a few times in the
city, but it allowed the property owners to
transfer development rights anywhere in the
neighborhood.
Normally, you can only transfer to an adjacent
property owner and if they don't need your
air rights or are already fully built-out,
you're out of luck.
So, this really created a market for these
air rights.
It helped us get the property owners on-board.
>>Joshua David: So then, with that work done,
we set about actually designing the park that
would be on the High Line.
And it was a very different process than the
design ideas competition that Robert was showing
you a little bit about before.
Those design ideas, they could come from anyone.
You didn't have to have any experience.
You didn't have to be an architect.
It didn't have to be financially rational.
It didn't have to be technically viable.
We were just looking for interesting ideas
that would broaden the way that you thought
about the High Line in the first round.
Now, what we were doing was looking for actual
teams of architects--multidisciplinary teams--that
could actually create a design that would
make this amazing, but challenging environment
open to the public.
And so, I think this picture really tells
the story of the challenge.
We loved going up there when it was like this.
And this is one of the many site visits we
did to better understand the site before we
entered into design.
But what would happen is if you went up with
a group like this--just a handful of people--by
the end of the visit, it was all trampled
down.
And this was an environment that we wanted
to open to the public, but the fact of opening
it to the public would destroy it.
So, the challenge that we gave to all of the
design teams that wanted to compete was how
do you create a landscape that's reflective
of this really amazing one that embodies the
power of nature to overtake monumental, man-made
structure and really show the power of nature.
And so, we had 51 design teams initially submit
applications.
They were all made up of teams of architects,
landscape architects, security consultants,
lighting consultants, historic preservation
consultants, signage people.
And then, we went down to seven teams.
And then, we went down to four teams in the
end that did the most detailed proposals.
So, I'll just show a few images from some
of the different teams that submitted.
This was a part of a proposal that was submitted
by Zaha Hadid's team.
This is the southern end of the High Line
near Gansevoort Street, where the Whitney
is now under construction.
So, one of the things that all of the teams
picked up on was that something was gonna
be built at that site.
So, this was her proposal.
It shows--.
Her environment was very swooping, white forms,
not a lot of landscape.
She did have an amazing landscape architect
on her team-- Diana Balmori.
But landscape really wasn't the focus of this
proposal.
And in one of the sessions where we were going
over it, it had an intermediate stage with
the various teams.
Robert asked Zaha, "Why aren't there any trees
in your proposal?"
And she told Robert, "Trees are what architects
do when they don't know what to do with the
space."
[laughter]
This is part of a proposal by Michael Van
Valkenburgh, was working with Julie Bargmann
on a team called Terragram.
It was a great proposal in many ways.
Some of the things that are in it are things
that are reflective of choices that we ultimately
decided to do.
This is a stair.
That's not so different from stairs that Diller
Scofidio and Renfro and James Corner ultimately
designed.
This is a structure.
This is Stephen Holl's team.
Stephen Holl had a really interesting history
with the High Line long before Robert and
I came along.
Stephen was working with another preservationist
who was trying to save the High Line back
in the mid-90s--a guy named Peter Obletz.
And they worked together for a little while
and then went their separate ways.
But Stephen is one of the original High Line
advocates and did an earlier phase of work
called "Bridge of Houses," which became very
famous.
So, we were thrilled to have him competing
in the end.
This is another image of his proposal.
But the team we ultimately selected was James
Corner Field Operations, working with Diller
Scofidio and Renfro and the Dutch horticulturist,
Pete Rudolf.
And this is a rendering from their competition
entry.
And it's really interesting how much it is
like what we actually built.
It's fairly rare for, in a competition phase,
for architects to put forth something that
doesn't get really drastically modified as
the process goes along.
And to have the renderings in the competition
phase actually be so close to what we actually
built is quite unusual.
You can see the--.
They were picked for this system that they
created, which they called "planking."
The walkway system that allowed the grasses
and plants to push up through the concrete
walkways very much the way that the plants
used to push up through the gravel ballast
of the High Line.
And this is also from their competition board.
And it showed how this system could be--was
a modular system--could be tailored to different
needs in different spaces.
So, in areas where you imagined you might
have a lot of people gathering, you could
have more hardscape--the planking system really
going from one side of the High Line to another--very
much like it is within the Chelsea Market
Passage.
And then different ways of varying the percentage
of hardscape to plantings to the point where
on the far right, you have a condition where
it's planted all the way from one side of
the High Line to another, which is what they
call the Flyover, the Flyover condition.
It was something that we thought was just
a concept that we would never do, so it was
really exciting when we actually ended up
doing it in Section Two.
So, this is the High Line under construction.
We did have to ultimately remove all of the
existing landscape that was up there to go
down to the bare structure.
We waterproof it, redo the drainage system.
Actually, the single most expensive part of
the project was repainting the structure.
It had originally been painted in lead paint.
So, it had to be put in containment units
and all sandblasted, primed, and repainted.
It was the single biggest part of the job.
And then here you can see the rail tracks
being reinstalled.
Before that rehabilitation of the structure,
we removed all the tracks, but they were all
surveyed.
So, whenever we put tracks back into the park,
they're the original tracks going back into
their original locations.
So, I'm gonna take you just--.
I'm sure most of you are pretty familiar with
the landscape of the High Line.
So, I'll just take you on a very quick tour
of it.
This is down--.
That walk--.
Oh, I'm not quite on the tour yet.
This is that walkway system actually completed
and viewed from above.
And the plantings, Pete Rudolf was the horticulturist
that we chose.
He was on their team.
And he was selected really because his pallet
of work really reflected what was originally
up on the High Line.
He was known for using very naturalistic massings
of grasses and perennials that really evoked
a natural-looking landscape, which you can
see in this picture here.
But he added in a lot of new plant species
into the mix so that you'd have vivid displays
all through the seasons.
We have things flowering up there basically
from February through November.
There's something that's flowering up on the
High Line.
This is a section in the Chelsea Grasslands.
This is things that are flowering up there
right now, the red buds.
And one of the things that Pete Rudolf specified
was that in the winter, a lot of times in
perennial gardens, all of the dead plant material
gets cut down before winter.
He specified that it all be left in place,
partly for the health of the plants.
It protects them from freezing and thawing.
But also because of the beautiful forms of
this dead material all by themselves, or when
there's snow or ice on them.
We also had an incredible lighting consultant--Herve
Descottes from L'Observatoire.
And one of the things they discovered in doing
their night visits to the High Line, before
designing the lighting system, was that because
it was so dark up there, your pupils didn't
contract.
When you're on the streets in New York, you're
constantly passing beneath these very bright
cones of light from the street lamps and it
makes your pupils contract.
And it makes it harder to see the night sky
and the buildings that are around you.
And they noticed when they were up there at
night, they didn't have that condition and
they could really see the night sky and the
buildings better.
So, one of the things that they aimed for
in designing the lighting was to always keep
it waist-level or below so it was never shining
in your eyes, but down on the walkway and
the plantings.
And these are the fixtures that they designed
to go into the railings and shine down onto
the plant material.
And that's the lighting system as it works
today.
And it's one of the things that makes evenings
on the High Line such a special and magical
experience really.
So, just a quick run from south to north from
the High Line.
Gansevoort Plaza, where the High Line was
chopped off in 1990.
And it was really jagged-edged, which the
design team proposed to polish it off to use
as a reveal, like a section of how the High
Line's built.
And that's it completed.
And then up the Gansevoort Stairs.
They designed their stairs.
They call them "slow stairs" and they were
designed to extend the experience of going
from street-level to the High Line level.
So, you had steps that were very gently graded
with long landings and a period in the middle
where you were actually passing through the
center of the structure and able to reach
out and touch the beams on the side and the
rivets that were all hammered by hand before
emerging in the planted environment up above.
This is another set of those stairs coming
through at 14th Street.
This is the Diller Von Furstenberg sun deck
between 14th and 15th Street, looking out
to the river.
One of the things that we did is we were thinking
about the spaces on the High Line, was thinking
of it not only as a track to get from one
place to another.
It was a linear transportation system and
I think people really thought about it a lot
as a way of moving from one space to another.
But we really wanted it to be a series of
social gathering spaces as well, where people
stopped and inhabited the spaces and stayed
for a while.
And so, that's why we designed these large
chair structures at the Diller Von Furstenberg
sun deck, which have become really popular
for social gathering spots.
Also why we brought in the water feature in
that location.
We're just about to turn it on in about a
week or so.
And it's one of the things that really draws
people to the spot, kids in particular, taking
off their shoes and playing in it.
This is the Chelsea Market Passage.
One of the amazing things it has in that historic
photo, the train going through the building.
This is a place where trains passed through
and brought loaded goods in and out of what
was the old Nabisco factory.
And it's really one of the things that makes
the High Line such an unusual urban condition.
You have public space, New York City, public
parkland, which goes through these donut holes
in private buildings.
And it's really the only instance that you'll
see of the public occupying this zone within
a private space.
The same space at night.
A wonderful little side walkway just north
of the Chelsea Market Passage.
And this was always one of Robert's and my
favorite features in Section One--the 10th
Avenue Square.
And its design evolved out of the challenge.
It runs over--.
This is over 10th Avenue.
And one of the things that we were gonna have
to do in this location was put up a high fence
on that northern run to protect against people
throwing things onto the Avenue below.
And so, we looked at a number of different
design solutions of how you could get away
with not having it.
And this was one of a whole bunch of proposals
of how you could actually use the structure
itself as its own eight-foot high fence.
And then, it took on a life completely of
its own as a design feature--and amphitheater
built within this space.
And here, you can see the incredible amount--.
It was the biggest engineering feat of the
whole project, was removing the large number
of massive steel girders that made that square
technically possible--taking them all out,
re-engineering the whole area so it could
become a little amphitheater in there.
And there you see it completed.
And it's really one of the landmark design
features of the High Line.
You can descend into the structure, watch
the traffic flowing beneath you.
And people stay there for a long time and
just watch the flow of traffic and the life
of the city streets below.
It's really a magical place.
This is the Chelsea Grasslands moving north
at the beginning of the 13th block straightaway
that runs through West Chelsea, followed by
the Chelsea Thicket, a more enclosed environment.
What the design team was really looking to
do in this area, because it is a straight
run that goes for 13 blocks, was thinking
about different ways to create a kind of room
about every two blocks.
So, the landscape is cohesive.
It's the same walkway system that's taking
you through it, but the landscape is changing
in subtle ways.
So, it's evolving into very different changing
environments about every two blocks.
This is the lawn at 23rd Street.
Very popular gathering spot.
And benches that were designed to integrate
an old rail platform that used to service
this warehouse building.
Those bays with the glass block used to be
loading bays for trains, accepting goods on
and off the High Line.
This is the Falcone Flyover between 25th Street
and 27th Street.
That flyover condition that had been shown
in the competition entry that we thought was
really just a concept, actually ended up getting
built.
And it's one of the great features of Section
Two.
It runs between these two warehouses that
when the High Line in its original--.
When we first started going up there, its
original landscape, a forest was growing in-between
those two warehouses because it was shadier
there and there was better moisture retention.
So, the plantings that are in the Flyover
area are ultimately gonna recreate that forest
condition.
They're gonna come up and envelop the Flyover
and it'll be as if you're walking into the
canopy of the trees.
That's the Flyover viewed from above.
Again, the Flyover viewed from above with
the 26th Street viewing spur.
Another instance of using a feature on the
High Line as a way to direct your attention
not to the High Line itself, but to the city
around you--very much like the 10th Avenue
Square.
And it's one of the things--.
The other things I think that's really special
about the High Line as a park.
Only a small part of the experience is the
zone of the park itself.
A much bigger experience is the way that you're
looking at the city around you.
And so, thinking about new ways of directing
a visitor's gaze and framing that gaze are
a very important part of what the design team
does.
That's--.
And it goes both ways.
Also at the 10th Avenue Square, the view from
the street up to those zones is as interesting
and compelling as it is when you're up there
looking down.
This is a zone coming down off of the Flyover
at 27th and 28th Street.
That same zone is called Wildflower Field,
a simple straight pathway that's planted to
be reminiscent of the original High Line landscape
that you saw in those Joel Sternfeld photos
earlier on.
The same section at night.
And then, we end at, in Section Two, at a
feature called the 30th Street Cut-Out.
It's the cement decking that actually held
up the ballast.
And the tracks has been removed, been cut
out.
And this viewing platform is lifted up slightly
so you get these great views out to the Hudson
River.
And it's one of the things that the design
team did a lot was to, instead of really concentrating
on adding major new features, they looked
at ways you could do subtractions the same
way as the 10th Avenue Square--remove something
to give you a different experience within
the High Line.
So, here, the decking has been removed so
that you can see the girders below.
And this is an elevated shot of the way that
the High Line moves through West Chelsea in
the Village.
And I think this is--.
This is what makes it such a special condition,
that you're snaking through the center of
these blocks, looking at the city from a perspective
that you otherwise never get to see the city
from.
And you can see it bringing us here up to
the West Side Rail Yards.
>>Robert Hammond: So, one of the ways--.
One of the reasons it's created so much value
is it's been a boom to development in the
neighborhood.
This is a map of over 40 different projects
that have already happened or are in the process
of happening.
One of the most exciting is that the Whitney
is moving downtown to the base of the High
Line.
It's already under construction.
This is a design by Renzo Piano.
It'll be about four or five times as big as
their current space, which they are gonna
be renting to the Met Museum.
And they'll be opening this in 2015.
And that, the little, shorter little building
right there that's black is gonna be our headquarters.
And we're gonna open that in about, hopefully
next year.
And the roof will be the largest outdoor sculpture
garden for the Whitney.
We talked about the 900 million dollars in
added tax revenues.
And this is just some of the things that's
already happened in and around the High Line.
There's two billion dollars in new construction
projects, again, in probably the worst economic
times in a while.
Twelve thousand jobs.
The other great thing is it's also not just
regular development.
A lot of it has been really interesting.
And there's a spot where you can stand here
at 18th Street and see a building by Frank
Gehry, Jean Nouvel, Shigeru Ban, Annabelle
Selldorf, Neil Denari.
So, in addition to running through three historic--.
Is it three?
>>Joshua David: Four.
>>Robert Hammond: Four historic districts,
you can also see some of the best new architecture
in the city.
So, when Josh and I met, one of the first
things we did was start Friends of the High
Line.
And that's what is still running the park
now.
And it's really this public/private partnership
and it was modeled after the Central Park
Conservancy.
So, we're a private group.
We don't work for the city that manages and
operates the park for the city.
We pay for a hundred percent of all the costs
of maintaining it.
The city pays for security and liability.
But the gardener--that's one of our gardeners,
Johnny.
All the gardeners, the maintenance workers,
the people taking out the trash, are all our
employees.
And they're paid for by members.
If anybody wants to become a member, we love
members.
Its membership starts at 70 dollars.
And they're working through all different
seasons.
That was not this year.
[laughs] And it is really hard to remove snow
because we can't use salt.
We have to do it all by hand and machine because
the salt--.
The planting, the water is recycled into the
planting beds.
So, if you use salt, it'll go into the plants.
So, we originally thought we'd have about
300 thousand visitors a year.
That's about how many the Whitney gets in
a year.
So, we thought that would be a good comparable.
Last year, we had three point seven million
visitors.
Our busiest day was Father's Day.
It would be interesting now, I sort of wanna
see a competition between Mother's Day and
Father's Day.
>>Joshua David: Mmm.
>>Robert Hammond: We hadn't opened Section
Two, so maybe that's why the dads went out
last year.
But just to see where the High Line lies with
other institutions, we have about almost a
million more than MoMa.
And this is crazy.
The Travel and Leisure did this poll of the
20 top world destinations.
And I think it's a little ridiculous we're
ahead of the Acropolis, but--.
[laughter]
>>Joshua David: Mmm.
>>Robert Hammond: One of the things that is
a fear of ours, that it becomes just for tourists.
And we want--.
And we're glad tourists visit and that it's
very popular, but we really want it mainly
to be for New Yorkers.
So, we do over 300 free programs throughout
the year.
And almost all of them are geared towards
locals.
A lot of them are kids-oriented.
This is a Step Festival we started last year
where kids compete from all five boroughs.
We're gonna be doing it again in June.
We do a lot of kid's programming.
This is in that 10th Avenue Square where we
used as an amphitheater.
Every--.
Throughout the summer, every Wednesdays and
Saturdays, we have something called Children's
Play, where they can build their own High
Line-esque structures.
We do a lot of musical performances.
We have salsa.
We're gonna have salsa dancing every Thursday
night once a month throughout the summer.
And we have stargazing every Thursday night
from now until the fall.
You just go up there and there's astronomers
up there that will bring up their telescopes
[Joshua David coughs] for you to look at.
And I didn't even know you could see any stars
in New York, but you can actually see the
rings of Saturn.
This is sort of an unfortunate slide because
you know one of the most famous things about
the High Line is watching people have sex
in the standard windows.
It's more of an urban myth than a reality.
But that's not what--.
When you see the people with telescopes, that's
not what they're there for.
[laughter]
Yeah, this is one picture of that.
One of the other things we do to keep, for
locals, and a reason to keep coming back is
art, is public art on the High Line.
This is a work by Spencer Finch.
And almost all of it is temporary.
So, it changes.
So, if you go up there right now, about 21st
Street, this is a work by Sara Zee.
It's actually going away in June.
So, it's always changing.
At any one time, there's about five or six
different projects up there.
This is where we--.
The developer had given up this billboard.
This is that Joel Sternfeld photo.
These are all different artworks.
This was a John Baldessari piece we put up
in the spirit of Christmas in December, which
was a hundred thousand dollar bill, which
was an actual legal tender that banks use
between themselves to transfer money.
And he blew it up the size of a billboard.
So, the High Line's also not done.
We have some great art.
And we have some great performances coming
up on Earth Day.
There's a woman named Alison Spear, who's
doing this thing called "Make a Salad," where
she had this work in the '60s where she'd
throw lettuce off a building and onto a tarp.
And then throw tomatoes and salad dressing.
And everyone does the tarp up and down.
And then, she serves the salad.
We're gonna do it off the High Line on Earth
Day.
>>Joshua David: Free salad for a thousand
people.
>>Robert Hammond: Yes.
So we're not done.
There's the last section of the High Line,
which is this part right here.
And it runs around the rail yards.
This is the last, largest undeveloped site
in Manhattan.
Here's where the Olympic Stadium was originally
gonna go here when New York was competing
against London, which won.
And it was gonna be the Jets Stadium as well.
It's the most beautiful part of the High Line.
Most of Joel's photographs were taken there.
You get great Hudson River views.
This was--.
That's the Jets Stadium that was defeated
by the community.
But now, it's gonna be developed for mixed-use
of retail, commercial, and residential by
the related companies.
So, it's gonna be 12 million square feet.
So, that's like downtown Seattle times two
all squeezed into these two sites with the
High Line running all the way around it.
And at first, they actually wanted to tear--.
Some people wanted to tear down the High Line
because they thought it would be easier to
develop if it was just an open site.
But we've won that battle.
And the city's been really supportive.
And everyone's agreed to keep all of the High
Line.
And our goal right now is to try to fully
build-out this portion of the High Line in
blue.
And then this green part, to do a temporary
walkway that could last for five or ten years,
that would get us all the way to 34th Street
by 2014.
And that's, it would be all the way to where
the Javits Center is.
And there's gonna be a new Number Seven subway--the
first new subway in Manhattan--I think in
75 years.
It's gonna open up around then, too.
I'm gonna skip.
I think we have some just--.
I wanted to show some of the slides of--.
Oh, no.
We don't have them in here.
I don't know.
Can you--?
Can you go back?
Oh, sorry.
[laughs] But what I wanted to show, and I
guess we didn't include them in here, is some
of the new slides for Section Three.
So, we've just released the designs of the
final section.
You can find them on our website that are
all there.
And that's where we're--.
We're still working on those and that's why
we've had so far, two community input sessions
on those designs.
So, people still have a chance to shape--.
>>Joshua David: Yeah, at the end.
>>Robert Hammond: what's happening there.
And I also wanna end on this.
This is my favorite programming that we didn't
even plan.
So, when we opened Section One in 2009, we
misdirected one of the lights that was supposed
to shine on the stairs.
And it shone in this woman's bedroom.
And she called to complain and we didn't do
anything 'cause we were busy.
But she, like a good New Yorker, made the
best of the situation.
And she had a friend who was a cabaret singer,
would go out on her fire escape and serenade
the High Line, people on the High Line.
She named it the Renegade Cabaret.
It lasted for several months until her landlord
told her she couldn't go out on her fire escape
anymore unless there's a fire.
So, but to me, what I like is it's just a
symbol how New Yorkers can respond to different
things.
The High Line itself was an accident.
It was meant to be a loaded freight line that
fell into disuse mostly in the '90s.
And the last train was in 1980.
So, it was an accidental park and so the kind
of programming that comes around accidentally
is to me what's, I think, most interesting
about the High Line.
So, I think we have a few minutes to answer
questions.
I guess I have a question for y’all.
Last time I came and spoke, everyone was on
their laptop working.
I don't know.
Is that a new culture that y’all do it?
I mean, it's nice that y’all are actually
looking at us, but I can't imagine that we've
gotten much better at speaking.
But--.
>>male #2: You spoke about how one of those
things that's going up near the undeveloped
space is gonna last for just ten years.
Why is that?
Why not longer?
>>Robert Hammond: Yeah.
So, we wanna open--.
We don't have enough money, basically, to
build the whole High Line out.
It would cost about a hundred million dollars
to build the full walkway.
And so, we only have about half that.
So, we're gonna build half of it fully and
then put a temporary walkway.
Some people said, "Well, why can't you just
keep the temporary walkway permanently?"
'Cause that's sort of an interesting condition.
But ultimately, we have to go through and
remediate the space.
So, we have to go in and do the lead paint
remediation Josh talked about.
And we have to go in and remove all of the,
put in new waterproofing.
So, it'll last five to ten years and then,
we would build-out it to a permanent level.
So, the idea is the walkway would be finished
after that.
>>male #3: So, I think I might have been there
that Father's Day.
[Robert Hammond laughs]
It was really crowded.
>>Robert Hammond: Yeah.
>>male #3: I mean, it's of course gonna get
more crowded.
So, what's the plan to somehow deal with that?
I mean, it's great that there's a lot of people,
but as it gets more crowded, you can enjoy
less of it, right?
>>Joshua David: I think it is one of the real
challenges that we're looking at right now
and looking at different ways that we can
address it.
One of the things that--.
The easiest way to deal with it is people
who are in the neighborhood or here every
day, is to think about the majority of times
it's not crowded.
There are lots of many beautiful times of
day to go--early in the morning, late in the
evening, during the week almost all the time
is manageable.
There are two very crowded times, which are
Saturday from 11:30 to about 5:30, and Sunday
from 11:30 to about 5:30.
So, those are times that as people who live
and/or work in the neighborhood, you have
the opportunity to take advantage of times
when it's not so crowded.
And we are looking at those more crowded times.
We're just about to start a new strategic
planning process.
And one of their group of central questions
that we're asking ourselves as an organization
and that's one of them.
How do you handle that issue?
Because it's not the experience that we created
the High Line to have.
It's great to be popular.
It's great to be loved.
But that's really challenging.
We did experiment when we opened Section One
and a little bit when we opened Section Two.
When we know there are gonna be very intense
crowds, based on something dramatic happening,
like the opening.
We actually did have to regulate the number
of people who came in.
And so, at those times, entrance points got
closed and you could only enter at one point.
And there was a line.
And that is a way that you can regulate it.
It's very labor-intensive, very expensive,
and people don't like it.
So, you have a whole bunch of negatives associated
with that system.
So, I don't think--.
That's not the answer, but we are looking
to further answers.
>>Robert Hammond: One of the dilemmas is also,
when we were thinking about Section Three,
one of the answers is you can make the path
wider so there's more room.
But the problem is, that takes away from the
planting.
I mean, with Section Two, we actually had,
the path is narrower.
So, you have more planting to path.
So, it feels more crowded, but for most people,
we hear they like it more because there's
more plantings.
So, there's the dilemma.
It's like highways.
Do you add another highway?
But then, you'd just get more people.
So, it's one of the things of trying to find
that right balance.
>>male #4: How did you, or how do you, plan
for very large plants that wanna get even
larger?
Like a tree that wants to grow 60 feet, who's
roots can only go down so far.
>>Joshua David: Most of the trees have been
selected to be moderate in size and to have
root systems that deal with the very confined
nature of the High Line.
One of the things when we planted it and opened
it, we really didn't know these plants were
gonna do.
It's a very forbidding condition.
There's only about that much soil there.
It's about 14 inches of soil.
And so for trees, that's an extra challenging
situation.
Where there are a lot of trees, we've done
some subtle additions to the way the planting
beds are designed to allow for more soil depth.
You see this down at the very southern end
of the High Line--what we call the Gansevoort
Woodlands, where there's a very dense grouping
of trees.
We've added a COR-TEN steel edge to the planting
bed, which gives us another two feet or so
of soil so that we can have all of those trees
there.
Those are also--.
Now, the whole High Line has an irrigation
system, but in the beginning, it was designed
just to have irrigation where the trees were.
So, they were given special watering systems
as well.
And I think over time, eventually, the root
systems will get too big on some of the trees
and they'll have to be replaced, as happens
in a lot of parks that have trees growing
in planters or confined areas.
>>Robert Hammond: And one other thing.
The planting depth is the average planting
depth is about 13 inches.
So, that's one of the amazing things that's
actually worked.
And you're basically on a bridge.
So, it heats from below and above.
And it's amazing that it--.
We were worried with all these plants that
they'd survive.
But a lot of them were selected about, I think
a quarter of them were actually plants that
were already growing up there.
So, we knew that they could thrive in that
kind of environment.
>>Joshua David: And the, what was up there
to begin with before we started, it was gravel.
There was not even any dirt in it.
So, it really, it has always shown remarkable
resiliency of nature to grow and vary in inhospitable
conditions.
And I think it's continuing to do that now.
>>male #5: I'm just curious.
With so many stakeholders with vested interests
in the various stages of your proposal, whether
it was the design competition, or whether
it was probably the transfer of property rights,
I was wondering who had ultimate decision-making
authority.
If it was the two of you, I'm wondering how
you were able to achieve that given--.
You guys weren't subject matter experts in
design.
You're not architects.
You're not urban planners.
So, was it just that you were the first two
of the most enthusiastic and so it gave you
that right?
>>Joshua David: Ultimately, it's a city project.
So, when we were designing and building, it's
ultimately the decisions all go up to the
city.
That said, it's been a remarkable partnership
between us and the Bloomberg Administration.
I think what was interesting was at the very
beginning, when the Bloomberg Administration
decided it wanted to do the High Line, they
were buying into an idea that they didn't
know very much about and we knew a lot about.
So, they welcomed us into a partnership that
was very productive because we had, at that
point, we'd assembled some expertise on it.
And the design team selection process was,
I think, a really unusual and interesting
example of the city and a non-profit working
collaboratively together around a table with
basically the same number of people on each
side.
We always acknowledged that ultimately, the
city had the call on anything that was gonna
happen up there.
But they gave us a very wide degree of discretion
in directing how the design was gonna go.
And so, I think it's been a really amazing
partnership.
There is also one element of the project that
goes up to the federal government level.
We're what's called a rail banked park, or
a rail banked trail.
There are different ways that railroads can
be reused as trails or park land.
And rail banking is one sector of that.
It's essentially a program that was created
by the government to allow rail carders that
go over private property to be maintained
and used for other uses without losing their,
without the easement going poof into the air.
So, that all had to go through a federal approval
process.
>>Robert Hammond: I mean, the other thing
is money.
[laughter]
We were raising private money, so that's also
what gave us a place at the table on important
design decisions.
And still gives us the role to be able to
run it because we're raising private money
to help supplement what would otherwise have
to be paid for by the public.
>>male #6: I noticed a change with the lighting
in the Chelsea Market Pass Through.
Initially, it was blue at night.
And it had two sets of fluorescent tubes,
one blue and one white for, I think, day.
And it looked like it started running both
of those tubes at night to make it more brighter
and also purple.
Is that true or can you tell us the story
why that changed?
>>Robert Hammond: Yeah.
So, I mean, there's a lot of back history
of the lighting in Chelsea Market.
One, we insisted on having it dimmer, which
the Parks Department was like, "Why does a
park need a dimmer?"
And I'm saying it was very important.
>>Joshua David: Mm-hmm.
>>Robert Hammond: But that was to try to create--.
If you just do the white light, it can be
very harsh.
And so, if you do the white and the white
and blue light, it creates a warmer light
when you're in there.
It's more flattering as well.
But the artist, during the day, doesn't like--.
There's the art piece on the wall.
Doesn't like how it looks with the blue light.
So, we try to use the light as little as possible.
And the blue light mainly just on certain
occasions.
On the 14th Street passage, we use both.
But it's really intended--.
You can do blue or white, but it's really
intended to have them both on at the same
time in the evening.
>>male #6: That was one of my favorite things,
was just the blue light only at night.
I mean, in the day, you can do different things,
but I thought that was cool.
>>Robert Hammond: Yeah.
The lighting is done by a guy named Herve
Descottes from L'Observatoire who came up
with that.
>>male moderator: I think we have time for
one more question.
>>male #7: So, congrats.
It's an amazing achievement.
The Meatpacking District is unrecognizable
today, right?
And so, some of it was not dependent on your
contribution, but you've actually accelerated
the development of this neighborhood.
Did you do anything to try to protect some
of the historical establishments and businesses
in the area?
'Cause for example, you can see the Whitney
sitting on top of all the Meatpacking District
locations, right?
>>Robert Hammond: I mean, I think the High
Line gets too much credit and too much blame
in some ways.
[laughs] I mean, the Meatpacking was changing
gangbusters way before we opened in 2009.
Florent had left before we opened.
I mean, I think the die was already set for
this.
But one of the great things that actually
Florent accomplished around the same time
we were getting started was making this an
historic district.
So, what that means is one, you can't change
a lot of the height, the character, like the
steel awnings.
The other thing that the neighborhood fought
and won for was not having residential.
And that's partly why it's such an entertainment
zone for bars and clubs and restaurants.
But it's also helped keep the character of
the buildings and not having them be all residential.
In certain ways, we don't have a lot of control.
We have control of what happens to the High
Line, but on what happens outside of it is
a little bit out of our control.
We can help certain people and work.
The good news about the Meat Market, the building--.
As part of the Whitney going in, the city
signed a long-term lease with the remaining
Meat Market vendors that are still there.
So, they'll be there for another at least
another 20 years.
>>male #7: Thanks.
>>Joshua David: Great.
Well, thank you.
[applause]